welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who you should always give
the silent treatment to
in this episode we're breaking down a
quiet place part two
the first film left me speechless
and in this video we're going to be
recapping and explaining the plot of its
sequel
whilst discussing the future of the
franchise this is a full spoiler review
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out then i highly recommend that you
mute this video now
click the thumbs up button if you enjoy
the breakdown and don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this each and
every day
without the way let's get into a quiet
place
part two shhh okay so once more we
follow the family who would do anything
for a quiet life
the first film in the franchise picked
up with the aftermath of an alien attack
that saw several super sensitive
creatures combing the landscape looking
for prey
the blind aliens had highly adept
hearing that meant they hunted on
sound and we watched as the abbotts hid
out at their farmhouse
whilst the monsters operated in the area
it was very
eerie and that's probably the worst pun
i've ever
said so if you leave i don't even blame
you however if you're still here
time codes will be linked below in case
you want to skip ahead to a certain
talking point
now evelyn played by emily blunt ended
up giving birth
and lee sacrificed himself so that his
children could survive
the movie culminated with evelyn and her
daughter reagan
realizing that there was a way to defeat
the creatures and them getting this
method out is very much the plot of this
film
now being labeled part 2 kinda signifies
the aesthetic of the movie
and this film actually ties heavily in
with the first entry
this flashbacks which set up key events
in it and even a moment where lee walks
past a rocket ship
toy this was in the introduction of the
prior film
and his youngest son ended up activating
it which led to his death
now whilst the opening of the film
doesn't explain everything about the
monsters
we do learn that they came from a comet
which passed over the earth
for lack of a better word the invasion
was extremely fast
and happened without warning or any time
for the government to prepare for what
was coming
everything was over in a matter of days
and why i was hesitant to use the word
invasion
it's because the creatures don't really
have any agenda or goals
they're simply monsters that by sheer
dumb luck ended up on our planet
and are now the top of the food chain
anyway it's an incredible way to open
the movie
and i absolutely love when films do
one-shot scenes
and this one is no exception it's
visceral and keeps your heart racing
as we see the nightmare that was brought
to earth
they should have went with the tagline
on earth no one can hear you scream hey
but i digress now from here the movie
flashes forward just over a year
and picks up immediately after the
events of the first part
evelyn has just cocked that shotgun and
he's ready to chew some bubble gum and
kick some
ass now you might remember that at the
end of the last film the sound of the
shotgun alerted several aliens in the
area
and they started rushing towards the
house unfortunately there's a bit of a
continuity error
as that isn't acknowledged and instead
the family are able to leave the
property pretty easily with their
newborn baby and children reagan and
marcus
they set out across the land to bring
people a message of hope
that will allow us to regain control of
the planet
and go back to destroying it ourselves
yay
now the first movie was very much about
the family learning to adapt to this new
world
and the follow-up film is about them
learning to adapt to no longer having ly
around
he of course taught them several things
and they discovered key survival tactics
on their own
that they're now using to go out into
the world with the movie very much ends
with the children stepping forward on
their own two feet
and destroying the monsters themselves
embodying both their parents
before departing regan also did
something similar to her father
and lit up a fire which caused one
across the landscape to be lit up too
in the film they head to this location
which we discover is the home of emmett
played by killian murphy emmett was a
friend of the family
and in the opening of the film he and
his children attended a kids baseball
game that marcus was playing at after
marcus sets off a bear trap
he ends up saving the family and we
learn that he's lived at this location
for several months unfortunately his
children were killed by the monsters
and his dying wife ended up succumbing
to a disease later on
marcus stumbles across her body and it
turns out that he cut himself off from
humanity
after seeing how vicious people could be
however he sees the family
namely reagan as a beacon of hope now
when discussing the character
killian said that he feels emma is a
metaphor for the world right now
and that he views him as someone who has
given up however
reagan represents someone who comes
along and allows you to believe in
yourself and
something greater this sets up the
second act of the film
which centers around regan going off on
her own in emmett's bunker the family
discover that the song beyond the sea
is being played on a constant loop and
this sound originates from a nearby
island
now this song carries a lot of meaning
with it as not only does it indicate
where there is sanctuary
but it also offers the idea of a better
life the song was originally sung by
jack lawrence
but it's been covered by several people
most notably bobby darin
whose version we hear in the movie it's
about a man who says somewhere beyond
the sea that his lover is waiting for
him
and the piece has been used in several
films typically it's put in place to
indicate that there are happier times
somewhere else
which the island represents as no aliens
occupy it
we discover that the aliens are unable
to swim and thus after they came to the
planet
the national guard moved as many people
as they could to this location
since then they've been living
relatively normal lives
sitting about watching tiger king all
day
unaware of this reagan simply wants to
travel to the location
and use the radio tower to transmit a
frequency that's harmful to the
creatures
and she ventures out there by herself
evelyn sends
emma out to bring her back but after he
discovers her plan
he decides to aid her now along the way
they search for a boat
and run into feral humans who look like
i did in the middle of lockdown
back at the base evelyn ends up
venturing out to the pharmacy from the
start
of both movies in order to get her baby
oxygen
she also goes to her child's grave and
places her wedding ring there
at this point marcus stumbles across
what i believe is emmett's wife's corpse
and he has to hide out with the baby in
the furnace as the pair slowly start to
suffocate
it's heart-pounding stuff with him
evelyn and the baby
and it's equally as terrifying on the
other side watching emmett have bottles
tied around him by the creepy humans
made me hole in a fart so that i
wouldn't alert anyone in the cinema or
on the screen
it's lines like that in my reviews why
rotten tomatoes won't approve me
but you know what i'm happy to die on
that hill emmett and reagan discover the
monsters can't swim
after he makes as much noise as possible
to draw them in in order to kill the
humans
after diving into the water one drowns
but another remains on a boat at a dock
which comes into play later they take a
bow and arrive at the island
which is where they meet damon honzo's
character who's simply referred to on
imdb
as man on island the other belt with one
of the aliens on it drifts into shore
and it starts mercilessly killing people
which makes honzu
reagan and emmet rush to the radio tower
man on island
becomes man on floor and he's killed by
one of the aliens as it stalks them into
the location
it's a very tense scene but reagan
manages to make it to the studio
here she plays the hearing device over
the mic and this sends the signal out to
everyone
back at emits marcus is able to
weaponize his signal
to use it on the monster outside and
finally the family is safe
now because of this signal transmitting
through the radio on loop
everyone has a weapon that they can use
to fight the creatures with
the first movie was very much about the
abbots finding a way to do this
but now they've passed on this knowledge
to those that are able to listen
i believe that the next film will center
around getting the rest of the family
stationed at this outpost
and from here they'll formulate a plan
to take down the monsters
once and for all now it should be said
that both the first and second film
and in ways that mean you can draw your
own conclusions
and close the book on the franchise
should you wish for it
however emily blunt in an interview with
collider said that there was potential
for a sequel
and that the door to a quiet place
trilogy was definitely open
the movie was actually screened for
people pre-pandemic
and the press carried out interviews
that discussed the film in general
and what could be happening next blunt
stated that krazynski had several ideas
for the future of the franchise
and if you cast your mind back to
november last year then you may remember
that a spin-off movie was announced
the hollywood reporter stated that
krasinski was working with jeff nichols
who you might know for his work on alien
nation and midnight special
nichols and krazynski are currently
putting together the script for the
piece
and when discussing the project the
latter said he had a unique idea that he
was really excited about
what's interesting is that he said most
spin-offs involved taking one key
character from something
and dropping them into a different
project however a quiet place was very
much about the world
around the humans he said that this
meant you could pick and choose any
person
and put them into this world and that it
would still feel connected
so i'm expecting something that's a
polar opposite to the setup of these
films
and instead of seeing things from a farm
family i'd love to get the pov of
someone either in the government or
military
in the movie it's mentioned that emmett
has a brother at a base
so i think that seeing things through
his eyes would be a really cool place to
start
there's also a scene in which reagan
walks past some high heels at a train
station
i would love to see this scene play out
and it just shows the kind of adventures
that they could go on
and how they could just show things from
different people's perspectives
i think most likely though that it will
be based around someone with authority
and power and how they had that all
stripped away and had to fend for
themselves
probably a bit of a tired subject but it
just shows how much the quiet place
universe can explore and tackle certain
things
i think from the way things are going
that we can expect to see the spin-off
within the next two years
and then hopefully the third installment
in the trilogy right after that there's
a lot to look forward to
and before we get into my overall
thoughts on the movie i just thought i'd
let you know that we're giving away
three free copies of the godzilla versus
kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now
and we'll be announcing the winners for
this one on the 30th of may so make sure
you get commenting
now as for my thoughts on the film again
this was another brilliant
piece of cinema that i really enjoyed
both parts are fantastic pieces of
horror
and my cinema was so quiet throughout
that you could hear a pin drop
yes that's because there was only about
three people allowed in it
but it's still such a captivating movie
and the sound design is once more
outstanding
there's so much atmosphere to it and i
love that you can bring you much shock
on these movies back to back
there were some showings of it that
played the first movie beforehand
and though i watched it at home to
prepare for the new one i kind of wish
i'd seen them back to back in that
environment
however i do know that the storming of
the house doesn't really lead to
anything
but that's a bit of a nitpick i think
the movie is really well acted
it's very tense and it does so much by
doing so little
i think that the next time though they
really need to ramp the stakes up
and give the family a definitive ending
instead of just leaving it slightly
open-ended like the last two but
you know it's part three so we probably
will get that now i'm not sure which are
the two that i prefer yet but the fact
that that's a difficult choice
shows how good this one is the first
movie was very much about home life
whereas this follow-up is about a
country decimated and they work
really really well as companion pieces
overall
a quiet place too was great and it
secures a 9 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the conjuring the devil made me do it
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the movie as a whole and
the real life events that inspired it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace